[Musik]
dann können wir uns jetzt mal um die
Erdbeercreme
heute gibt es eine erdbeereistorte mit
einem richtig leckeren und saftigen
pistazienboden
[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen in Sallys Welt
die Erdbeerzeit wird jetzt richtig
ausgenutzt dafür bereite ich jetzt
erstmal den pistazienkuchen zu und habe
hier folgende Zutaten ihr braucht dafür
3 Eier 150 g Zucker etwas Salz und
Vanilleextrakt jeweils 150 g Buttermilch
und Sonnenblumenöl 225 g Mehl plus
Backpulver oder nimmt einfach das
backmehl 100 g gemahlene Pistazien und
den Saft und die Schale einer Limette
zuerst gebt ihr jetzt die Eier den
Zucker das Salz und das Vanilleextrakt
in eine Rührschüssel und verrührt die
Zutaten für etwa 5 bis 10 Minuten
perfekt sieht die Masse jetzt aus und
jetzt gibt er hier die Buttermilch und
das Sonnenblumenöl dazu die Zutaten nur
kurz bei niedriger Stufe einrühren damit
die eingeschlagene Luft nicht wieder
entweicht
und ich habe jetzt hier das Mehl mit dem
Backpulver also das backmehl das muss
auch nicht gesiebt werden und die
Pistazien die ich bereits gemahlen habe
die kommen jetzt hier auch mit rein
gemeinsam mit dem Abrieb und Saft einer
Limette und jetzt nur ganz vorsichtig
und kurz unterrühren
der Teig ist jetzt angerührt ich habe
den Ofen bereits auf 170 Grad ober
Unterhitze vorgeheizt und habe einen
Tortenring auf 25 cm eingestellt und
weil der Teig etwas flüssiger ist hier
mit so einem Springform Boden
ausgestattet alternativ könnt ihr
natürlich auch den Tortenring einfach
mit Backpapier einschlagen da gibt's
auch schon Videos von mir auf dem Kanal
wie ich euch das zeige jetzt hier den
Teig einfüllen und ich streich das hier
am Rand immer gern so ein bisschen hoch
damit der Teig noch gleichmäßiger
durchbackt und dann einfach im
vorgeheizten Ofen backen danke
müsst ihr natürlich nicht machen denn
ihr könnt einfach die Sallys Welt
verwenden die ist natürlich mit eurem
Backofen connected dann könnt ihr die
Einstellwerte an euren Backofen senden
und müsst die Temperatur die Heizung und
die Zeit nicht mehr einstellen nur noch
am Ende dicker machen
für die Füllung verwende ich 300 Gramm
Erdbeeren 50 Gramm Zucker etwas
Vanilleextrakt Zitronensaft und Agar
Agar ihr könnt jetzt hier natürlich auch
gefrorene Himbeer nehmen Erdbeeren
sind immer noch es ist immer noch ein
Erdbeerkuchen könnt auch gefrorene
Erdbeeren nehmen und die einkochen aber
jetzt ist er gerade erst bei Zeit
deswegen nehmt ruhig die frischen
Erdbeeren alle Zutaten einfach in den
Topf geben mit dem wacker zerstampfen
und schön einkochen lassen
und sobald das Sprudeln kocht stelle ich
jetzt hier den Herd und ein auf 2
Minuten und dann kann der Herd quasi
runterzählen und es kocht 2 Minuten lang
sprudeln ein bisschen länger ist auch
nicht schlimm aber bisschen kürzer geht
nicht denn dann wirkt das Agar nicht und
die Masse wird nicht fest
[Musik]
jetzt stelle ich eine Erdbeercreme her
nämlich aus unserem Erdbeerpüree das ist
jetzt bereits komplett abgekühlt und das
wird jetzt eine richtig leckere cremige
erdbeerplastiker
Mascarpone
dafür verwende ich mein Erdbeerpüree das
richtig abgekühlt ist 500 g Mascarpone
50 g Puderzucker 400 g Schlagsahne und
danach zum steif schlagen
jetzt nehmt ihr einfach das Erdbeerpüree
hier in eine Schüssel dann kommt da
jetzt die Mascarpone dazu und etwas
Puderzucker und das ganze wird jetzt
kurz cremig verrührt
kommt hier die Sahne dazu und mit
sannaparte wird alles steif geschlagen
die Creme habe ich jetzt kurz in den
Kühlschrank gestellt der Boden hier ist
auch schon komplett abgekühlt den dürfte
jetzt hier einmal gerne rauslösen und
dann einmal waagerecht halbieren ich
habe mir jetzt noch überlegt natürlich
müssen noch Erdbeeren mit in den Kuchen
in die Torte also habe ich hier die
Erdbeeren schon vom Grün befreit und die
werden kurz gewürfelt
[Musik]
perfekt
aber so ein bisschen rosaner wünsche ich
dir mir schon so für die Farbe entweder
könnte jetzt gefräge getrocknetes
Erdbeerpulver noch dazu geben damit es
auch geschmackliche intensiver oder gibt
es eine Farbmasse dazu denn die ist mir
noch ein bisschen zu blass wir haben sie
noch gar nicht probiert ne
Erdbeereis dann nehme ich jetzt den
ersten Tortenboden der kommt direkt auf
die Tortenplatte da kommt das
Himbeerpüree drauf
[Musik]
warum
sind Erdbeeren
drauf
und an der Seite und dann kommt die
dickere Schicht
dann nehme ich so eine kleine
streichpalette und damit kann ich jetzt
den Rand schön glatt streichen und ich
mache die Torte nicht ganz glatt sondern
eher so ein bisschen wellenförmig
aus und jetzt kommt noch der Sally Trick
denn ich mag es nicht wenn die
Tortenplatte schmutzig ist also nehme
ich so einen Teigschaber ihr könnt
entweder vorher Backpapier Streifen
drunter legen oder nimmt dann einfach
den Teigschaber und nimmt hier so alles
runter
dann sieht es mega professionell
jetzt dreht ihr einfach die Torte und
zieht mit der Palette so ein
Wellenmuster rein und dann finde ich so
richtig gut und so ist die Torte
prinzipiell schon fertig es fehlt nur
noch die Deko obendrauf die mache ich
aber gleich ich stell die Torte jetzt
erstmal in den Kühlschrank zum richtig
gut durchkühlen
für die Deko halbe ich jetzt hier die
Erdbeeren wobei die ganz Kleinen die
lasse ich sogar im ganzen das Grün lasse
ich auch dran sieht nämlich hübsch aus
und das Erdbeer grün kann man auch
mitessen falls Sie das nicht wusstet
wenig Smoothies oder so macht dann lasse
ich es auch immer gerne mit dabei und
jetzt eine ganz einfache Deko die aber
wirklich sehr beeindruckend ist ich habe
jetzt hier gefriergetrocknete Himbeeren
weil ich keine Erdbeeren mehr habe das
kommt jetzt hier so als Pulver drauf
danke
[Applaus]
fertig und so kann die Torte jetzt
probiert werden sieht richtig gut aus ne
und wenn ihr da jetzt wirklich eine
Erdbeermilch als Torte machen wollt dann
stellt ihr sie jetzt am besten noch für
eine Stunde ins Gefrierfach dann ist es
so halb angeeist ich glaube das machen
wir jetzt
gibt es eine Eistorte
richtig hübsch
okay diese Torte wird jetzt probiert
vom Besten Torten verkostet der Welt
du brauchst dich sagen man sieht
cooler konnte leider nicht jetzt kommt
der Stellvertreter Moment
deswegen finde ich
wirklich das muss nicht jedem schminken
okay
[Gelächter]
cool nein der Teig ist genial weil er
ist cremig und hä was ist da rein
gemacht
aufgefallen dass die Konsistenz ein
bisschen der ist nicht hat aber ein
bisschen teuer
probieren
die cremigen
auf jeden Fall
die kann man jetzt noch
den ganzen Kuchen ist
aber man kann sie noch ein bisschen
anfrieren lassen dann ist es so eine
geisteste
geil
und kommentiert in den Kommentaren
okay
Rezepte und schreibt mir gerne mal was
bisher euer absolutes Erdbeer
Lieblingsrezept ist und die Erdbeeren
vom Bauer
regional zu kaufen bitte macht es auch
unterstützt eure bauen in der Region so
wie es auch machen
ich weiß es nicht immer möglich aber
gibt
definitiv und das Rezept oder auch.de
tschüss
[Musik]